[Music]
order
my name is nostalgia critic I made a
wrong turn somewhere because I'm face to
face with a mysterious glowing building
I hold my ancient ninja weapon a gun in
relaxed wear a physician I'm shocked to
discover my closest of friends yet
greatest Aventis black nerds doc what's
going on here I'm finally doing it I'm
making an authentic Ninja Turtles movie
what I'm putting in everything that's
been missing Krang is one of the
villains his giant robotic body I take
the drove in incredibly pointless I on
top it sounds plausible downright
perfect yet something seems off tasty
isn't it yummy well if it isn't my old
friend
really you're you're playing Casey Jones
what he's a whiny good-looking
complainer with a clean haircut right no
that's not what Casey's liked it all
about in Rock Steady's of token rods are
a black Baxter Stockman like from the
original comic Footloose gonna be good
it should work it should be amazing so
why is something telling me it's all
gonna go I can't wait to see Krang in
this movie I've been waiting years to
see excuse me do you mind you're
interrupting my war boxes oh don't you
talk about my word boxes I like word
boxes help me out here would you oh yeah
I'm totally invested Tamra you've been
with us before how come he seems so
disinterested this time around oh I'm
really interested my miniskirt got like
two inches shorter from Vanagon eternal
ban that shoots manhole covers they cuss
out in stores turtle gadgets rocket
skateboard stuff look like nerd I know
you mean well but I just get a feeling
this is all gonna backfire yeah it's all
seems a little hey guys what do you say
we talk about our dicks and make fart
jokes all day be bot misguided we get
the money to do this anyway Oh
from him
hi guys
ah ah you can't trust him oh come on
he's not making the film he's just
financing it yeah you won't even notice
I'm here Oh God has such a pretty movie
you mind if I touch it sure
put your finger it's all over it
Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles out of the
shadows the follow-up to the Michael Bay
produced hit from 2014 everyone got
excited for this movie because it was
finally giving everything that the fans
always wanted I mean everything bebop
and Rocksteady
Baxter Stockman the Technodrome the
turtle van and most notably Krang one of
the biggest villains how did we react to
it it sucked
Oh hmm some things are amazing and a ton
of fun to watch but other things are it
sucked
yeah we got so what did this movie get
right and when this movie get wrong
we'll strap on your giant mechanical
nunchuck arms that's cool
we'll get to it this is Teenage Mutant
Ninja Turtles out of the shadows not to
confuse the video game of the same name
as video game understanding there is
that like turtles 3 turtles in time but
was a cultural santel whatever Nintendo
was a good guy is it part of the crime
scene the turtle powers of the full
knowledge in a boat has no current
economy it opens with New York looking
unhealthily green they've been infected
by a nuclear shamrock shake as the
turtles are seen jumping off the
Chrysler Building to pick up a pizza
seems like a detour when we'll find out
more ways to destroy your creation the
movie then literally spells out their
names
yeah thanks we would have forgotten if
you didn't remind us watching Game of
Thrones we can remember who these four
are but they were also nice enough to
list their marketable character
stereotype
they go to a Knicks game because if you
like Ninja Turtles you obviously also
like basketball where it's revealed that
Vern played again by Will Arnett is
given credit for defeating the shredder
how the hell is anyone supposed to
believe that
but when dangers from the heart of our
city he single-handedly battles shredder
locking him up behind bars hey guys just
I let you know that I just
single-handedly defeated Godzilla so if
you'll excuse me I'll be off to get the
key to the city oh good for you Malcolm
yeah I'll just blindly believe that wait
how did you defeat him it can't ask
something like that
that's totally uncalled for I'm sorry
Malcolm he doesn't get it yeah take care
of your friend
my pals problem with you we all know who
the real monster is the Turtles then
shoot spitballs at him because it's
clearly more important than stopping
crime and they seem to get a direct hit
I think they're all having simultaneous
strokes they get a call from April
played again by Megan Fox who's
following a scientist named Baxter
Stockman played by Tyler Perry who she
thinks is working for the shredder
either that or Medea is undercover as
Neil deGrasse Tyson Neil deGrasse Tyson
really yeah Neil deGrasse Tyson you're
sure that Tyler Perry as Baxter Stockman
doesn't look like anyone else you can
think of nope
fine Tyler Perry's Baxter Stockman
College like me really I was just gonna
say he looks like the original comic
another you mention it yeah it look
exactly like him
haha there's a big difference I'm a nerd
not a geek it's the difference between
like TED Talks and oh my god yeah uh uh
downloading information off of his iPad
but gets taken away before she can get
all of it it has truly been an honor to
meet you and you were really one of the
greatest minds of our generation huh so
most women get out of a conversation
with Michael Bay speaking of which
insert our Cotuit is sexy shot as April
finds an emergency schoolgirl uniform
Stan to disguise herself
[Music]
Maybelline for your random spot light
appearing pantyhose vanishing
kleptomaniac tendencies
they'll be 94 25 bitch wow I didn't know
such a lame excuse could get somebody
into skimpy clothing Oh Tamra black nerd
is holding some information for us and
the only way he'll spill it is if
somebody dress us up in a Harley Quinn
uniform accommodate us
no but Michael Bay said you would know
first season Harley Quinn okay I'm not
Megan Fox you can't just easily replace
me if I don't do what you want no of
course not
now which of these baseball bats looks
better that's our camera we then see the
shredder being hauled to jail and wait a
minute who's this guy I know we didn't
really see the shredders face in the
first film but even from that shadowy
outline we know this isn't the same guy
even his reveal is nothing last time it
was a big mystery what he looked like
and now it's just oh hey I'm shredder no
biggie
he's unmask the majority of the film
that would be like if Michael Myers was
walking around without a mask yeah it's
like saying this chris'll Donnell
look-alike is Casey Jones hey Jones
Rowe yours well Casey Jones is a
pissed-off vigilante he hates the
justice system because he thinks it's
broken resulting in a short fuse badass
who doesn't play by the rules think
Rambo meets Jason what's this guy's
story that's officer Jones and I'm gonna
be a detective someday clothes just take
the exact opposite of everything he was
and that's him look the guy playing him
Stephen Amell is a good actor he's
proven that time and time again but in
this movie they're just not giving us
who Casey Jones is what a big Daddy
lawbreaker ready to forget how awesome I
was in arrow you got
32 counts of first-degree murder awesome
damn take it from someone who has his
own problems with anger-management
issues
who and that must mean he's a badass he
has anger management issues I myself am
a hockey guy I bone-crushing on ice does
movies overcompensation is like that kid
who says my mommy thinks I'm tough here
we go
so Baxter Stockman and the Foot Clan
ambush the truck to break him out
actually why do they even meet the
shredder it looks like they're doing
pretty damn good without him yeah I
think it's like losing Ted Healy from
the Three Stooges it's not a big loss
then just giganticus okay that was
awesome and they're gone
and the coolest thing only lasts a few
seconds get used to that get used to
life that is your real name this year
but back so using the teleportation
device to bean shredder away resulting
in him somehow meeting up with
everybody's favorite alien brain Krang
oh you like a buddy dr. Stockman found
something to buy the teleportation
device and now it's time to play why is
this awesome but this is awesome as we
thought it'd be Krang looks pretty good
even with the modern-day updates but for
some reason they give his body this
cluttered mechanical head instead of the
traditional bald head from the cartoons
I wouldn't mind so much except in the
trailers they clearly did give him the
bald head so why change it no no that's
not the reason the real reason is
because Krang barely gets an
introduction before he jumps into
immediately throwing a ton of plot at us
like a time that device is part of a
machine called the arc capacitor it
broke apart into three pieces I like the
other two pieces I launched the arc
capacitor to s dimension it will open a
portal through which I could bring the
Technodrome we barely have a chance to
take him how awesome it is is he crying
on the big screen because everything in
his movie is so quickly rushed no that's
not the reason either the big issue is
his voice that's Brad Garrett who's
usually a
pretty good choice but he comes across
as really random in this oh I'm sorry
did I get a little tentacle mucus in
your eyes the inflections the pitch the
attitude none of it seems to have any
direction
anyone with the weird distinct voice can
do it I said anyone with a weird
distinct voice can do it I'll be right
back that's a good question um I guess
my favorite one is Pacific Rim they
forget about the whole drifting things
they had one part that was just separate
from all the rest
oh go alright wait what am i doing I'm
trying to show that the voice of Krang
is very random and anyone with the
distinct voice can do it so do some
distinct voices like what ah anything
you're good at this come up with any
distinct voice you can think up these
back and forth shots are very difficult
to head it how about a little walk it
shredder
shame on you I see more than just an
expensive bomber I want to give you more
power
ooby do I want to be like you whoo-hoo
and fuck the cops fuck oh but Sam
Elliott has different plans I want to
use the Technodrome a menage ram to
steal all the good sex Barilla I'm
talking about the kraang gear with the
help of dr. Stockman that's heavy
using the plutonium God from the Libyans
are gonna make this town disappear
faster than the Back to the Future
animated series beautiful nicely done
great
did you literally drag me here just for
this well I can't really think of
anything else to do with your talents
wait a second what if we turned him into
a mutation of all the nostalgic Saturday
morning cartoons really Oh like the
comedy of the Ninja Turtles Cowabunga
dudes and the strength of lion-o
Thundercats oh the brilliance of Batman
by the night my god this could be
amazing
go jump Bailey create the brains
combination 70 morning cartoons on that
oh my god I'm so excited
uh I can't wait to see what he comes up
with he's a good kid yeah what makes
things even stranger is how willing
shredder is just to go along with this
weird brain's domination plan literally
in seconds he agrees with it we can
breathe the people of your planet to
their knees I'm interested no no the
correct answer is who are you what are
you where the hell is this what what we
then cut to Laura Linney as the police
chief because a woman in a pantsuit will
balance out a woman in a short skirt hey
we're great for black people and
transformers - her only job is to roll
her eyes and say nope wrong ah you
proved to be an authority on nothing
don't take help from someone who's
responsible for losing them and where
did you recover this leave this manhunt
to the professionals when will people
learn that the doubting police chief in
movies is always right she throws Jones
off the case because big surprise they
don't believe his story about giant
turtles thanks for your statement Jones
that's officer Jones look I can help you
catch these guys I'm not crazy I know
these streets better than anyone
[Music]
but it's okay because he decides to
solve the case himself and you better
watch out because when he goes rogue he
roughs up people's glasses oh he's
really off the rails and the original
film he's beaten the shit out of bad
guys but here he's throwing CDs see
these nuts are you out of your mind get
in there
does this fall more under interrogating
or temper taters I love this song but
hey it was a Vanilla Ice CD Denny
through so that's a reference yeah
that's a point I have a GPS you find
them with diet so shredder finds the two
inmates who helped him escape cult bebop
and rocksteady
and uses them as test subjects for one
of krang's weapons now in most
incarnations they mutated by combining
people with animals using the same booze
that made the Turtles simple makes a lot
of sense so what's the complicated
reasoning here inside every human
there's a dormant gene which ties us to
our animal ancestors
it's as if that purple ooze has returned
him to their rightful place in the
animal kingdom what the hell are you
talking about animal and sessom but what
was wrong with just put the hose on him
and combine him with other animals does
this mean other people have animal
ancestors like Snoop Dogg was actually a
dog Taylor Lautner was actually a llama
Wallace Shawn was actually a seal hey
did his hopper what are you descended
from Tyrannosaurus Rex the Lizard King
the story behind the rock band is making
more sense than yo your right nostril
and your uh I don't know what you were
hey Timon time to make our obligatory
cock joke mmm Pumbaa not in front of the
kids
and yeah have fun sitting dick pics to
the cast of The Jungle Book well it goes
along great with their fart jokes well I
got a big bang for you how's the cartoon
for kids coming across as more adult
April sees what happened and tries to
escape but Casey's there to save her
wearing his trademark hockey mask and
this is the only time you'll see him
wear it did you enjoy it
no too bad Casey's introduced to the
Turtles I'm trying to figure out the
best way to track bebop and Rocksteady
but he doesn't want anything to do with
it I was doing just fine well your work
done don't spend time at the zoo I'm
gonna find them no it's like they say
[Music]
they on the CW but Donatello makes an
amazing if not totally nonsensical
discovery if Krang zoos can turn people
into animals perhaps it can turn the
Turtles into humans maybe if they
combined it with that Super Nintendo
controller on his arm we can get a
really good turtles game we don't need
that kind of change but Weil says no
without consulting the others which
eventually makes its way to Raph in my
count you should consult with us before
you decide to do something like that
there's only one boat that counts in
this family mine
well at least they keep the most
important of turtle traditions leo is
always the worst leader Master Splinter
will be very upset tapas vigilante
nonsense will you act like a jerk
sometimes I can't believe you come on
what were you thinking go ahead we don't
need you i order you to stay I'm better
than you
is there an ood that just transforms you
into less of an asshat Raph and Mikey
want to break into police headquarters
to get more than ooh so they call on
burne to help them sneak in guys like
you and me were kind of the same right
now we bring a lot of joy and hope into
people's lives I will erase your Isabeau
jack in one single performance nobody
need to go bring that key to the city
with you Michael Bay gets tired of
making the military look like idiots so
he turns to making the police look like
idiots as our heroes easily sneak past
them with Megan Fox saying cowabunga and
not the turtles win Wow gotta love that
incredible look of shock and horror on
April's face did she find out they're in
trouble or try to hold back a fart in
fact a lot of Megan Fox's performances
underplayed we're in the first film she
was at least passable and clearly trying
since most movies about her here she
sounds like a lifeless computer
generation than the actual lifeless
computer generations looking at the data
from Baxter's iPad excuse me I named it
we need to find shredder that footages
been altered Baxter is working with the
Foot Clan I want you to be the hero that
the whole city thinks you are April but
not amused
April BOTS only trying when in
schoolgirl fetish mode but the turtles
are stopped by the police wait we're the
good guys around what are those things
and monsters they're monsters monsters
hey green lives matter oh we could still
shoot you okay whatever have a good day
the turtles are of course bummed out and
how the people looked at them she'd just
seen the looks on their faces weren't
you scared there was actual heat it's
like when they released our images
online it will be all right listen I got
something but enough of that emotional
stuff because this movie can't take two
seconds without moving somehow seems
Donny can track bebop and rocksteady DNA
because of course he can okay guys I
drew up some sketches I was thinking my
character should have like Jojo tanks
for arms and like he-man swords for
fingers brilliant Jon go perfect your
creation this could be so cool he's
adorable when he's happy
I want to bottle him up
you
so the turtles catch a plane to Brazil
where bebop and rocksteady are only to
find they're flying back directly under
them that's quite a coincidence and how
are we breathing up here
how can a plane still fly with no tail
ah this tank scene is awesome sorry
finally the turtles fighting bebop and
rocksteady
on the big screen yeah did you guys
enjoy that hell yeah good cuz it's the
only time that the turtles fight bebop
and Rocksteady in the entire movie flame
instead what do we get more of Leonardo
being a dick again thanks guys
mil Tina what do you know about anything
you're all heart no brain you may be
brothers we are not a team worst leader
ever but don't worry even after Laura
Linney's see the turtles with her own
eyes she still doesn't believe Casey or
April about there being more mutants
like them
the only real monster in the city of
shredder and the two mutants that he's
created bebop and rocksteady
if you think anything coming out of your
mouth is gonna add to her credibility
you are sorely mistaken
what is wrong with her she saw the damn
things she has no reason not to believe
them still over a phone call
I don't know anybody anything there's
even altered security footage with bebop
and rock state I was in there but now
they're erased out and they're advanced
police technology doesn't catch on that
it's a fake that footages been altered
it's been edited
we checked its authenticity it's clean
way to be proven wrong later how the
chucking shell do they even check
authenticity then do they do any actual
police work guys
remember how you defeated Godzilla
before
yeah but how did you oh well there's an
even bigger monster out there and we
need your help to get rid of him hmm I
don't know police chief what do you
think they have no idea what they're
talking about it makes me so mad I want
to bawl my eyes out and follow my head
and disgust oh here's the police chief
yeah she's in that position for reason
but you can see the monster I defeat it
before there's literally no reason not
to trust us I've checked the
authenticity of our eyes and they are
not clean oh gee check the authenticity
okay screw you guys I've got a city to
say ridiculous none of you have any idea
what you're talking about
your disgrace to law enforcers
everywhere sheesh Tamra I feel a lot
better earlier well thanks guys okay I'm
here
so she can look like that crying enters
our world through a portal in the sky
because that's the only transportation
that exists anymore as the turtles try
to figure out what's going on acting
into the main data core ships designate
is the Technodrome commanding officer
goes by the name of Krang good God I
don't Donatello does machines but is
there anything Donnie's technology
doesn't know you're making pity gadgets
book computer look like a samsung note
seven it decide it's probably best if
they blend in so Leo leaves it up to the
rest of his brothers to decide whether
or not they should use the ooze to make
them human I'll do whatever you guys say
it's your call
I say fuck this pointless plus red what
so we never seen him as human what a
missed opportunity
yeah and for the guy who claims Leonardo
makes all the decisions he sure did make
a decision to smash the news without
asking the rest of his brothers talk
about a pointless waste of an awesome
idea I've done I've created the most
incredible character to turn into super
Thunder Morphin bat ninja he Joe the
coolest mutation you've ever seen in
your lives my body is ready transform me
you know what man we thought about it
it's just not worth it what if this
movie taught us anything it's don't give
the audience exactly what they want just
tease them with it but yet bullets for
nipples and fire for nose hairs but
don't you feel like you've learned a
valuable lesson no well that's your loss
not mine bye
after Baxter sets up the portal big
surprise shredder betrays no I'll be a
god you'll be just what you've always
been a parasite an insect a half human
half bug hybrid the footnote oh you suck
it was right there could they just see G
in a fly landing on him to give us hope
uh everyone's betraying everyone as
shredder dressed like a ninja Eiffel
Tower is frozen like a bitch and stored
with the other Smash Brothers trophies
back to the toy chest
the things nice bro kid that was our big
villain this shrimp ever not go out like
an asshole
I want a conquerors I guess not
so April Vern in Casey try to sneak in
this in the Technodrome back to its
dimension actually we don't yeah your
performance was pretty forgettable by me
uh I have tits oh if only I had my
intimidating hockey mask yeah then you
know I'm a guy with anger management
issues but Casey locks them in a crate
and potentially murders them yeah yeah
beeps my man wasted line yo my man now
it's all look at our dicks internals
approach kraang and try to defeat it
I'll only warn you once cut off by sir
Donnie you heard him get off his ship
[Music]
come on Vern ticker on I have ten so to
shame a different electromagnetic
portion of portals from there yay
science babble so we never do see the
fully put together Technodrome techno
blows but April is still there to report
on it oh yeah she's a reporter forgot
what was that threat from the sky and
how exactly was it averted but the
bigger question is does it even matter
and will I ever act like I give a shit
in another movie again the turtles are
rewarded by New York's dumbest and
apologize for being such loudmouth
idiots all rewarded except for splinter
who is just in the corner watching
awkward Leonardo Raphael Donatello
Michelangelo last name oh not so much
its splinter I raised them but don't pay
any attention to me I'm just the reason
they exist I think we'll stick with the
arrangement we've had but it looks like
the turtles are happy staying a secret
in New York so it's more of a peeking
out of the shadows you could live a
normal life what fun is that
yeah one of the shadows but not really
you're being spotlighted where a lot of
people can see us I'm so confused
so that was Teenage Mutant Ninja Turtles
out of the shadows how was it cow some
things are really cool
many of the action scenes are creative
and energized but the plot never takes a
break from throwing shit at you it's
amazing seeing Krang bebop and
rocksteady but it would have been even
more amazing if they were in a movie
that had more weight to it it really is
like one long version of the cartoon
which sounds perfect in theory I love
that we get more references and band
service but even for Ninja Turtles we
still a movie that makes sense
even though the original film didn't
have everything be treated it like it
was a film they took time to set things
up and establish atmosphere this movie
just kind of goes from one crazy thing
to another crazy thing without any of it
ever adding up so I guess if you want to
see one long live-action version of the
turtle cartoon right down to the hokey
writing and rushed subplots this is the
turtle movie you've been waiting for but
if you're looking for a movie that
captures everything awesome about the
Turtles this gets it right sometimes but
feels like a mess all the other terms
and speaking of wit look a giant monster
Malcolm and Tamara were talking about
before anyway
there's nothing to see out there there
you're my god Michael Bay's crappy
influence have gotten so large he's
become gigantic that's nothing you know
how crank mind was in his stomach we'll
take a look where mine is
hey guys oh hey I have Cuse into one I
love to destroy anything has finally
resulted in the description of your
species
Oh only we can fight a horrible idea
with an equally horrible idea hello
Malcolm yeah it turns out my animal
ancestor was a giant platypus bunny I
just played around with that dormant
gene and Here I am now if you'll excuse
me I'm going to go brief buyer these
guys because that's what platypus
bunnies can do rocket feet away
well there's only one thing to say after
a crazy adventure like that I know
exactly what you mean yeah what's really
weird yeah I don't feel we earned man
yeah yeah Turtles three NES instead yes
I'm good at a while hey it's been a good
don't forget super thunder Morphin been
dang
[Music]
hey Doug Walker here doing the charity
shout out this week we are doing prevent
blindness founded in 1908 prevent
blindness has become the nation's
leading volunteer eye health and safety
organization dedicated to fighting
blindness and safe sight focused on
promoting a continuum of vision care
prevent blindness touches the lives of
millions of people each year they get
the word out on better eye health and
support groundbreaking research every
grant they get promotes the core mission
of preserving sight through their focus
initiative they support the collection
and publication of prevalence and
economic data to help health care
providers make better decisions about
eye and vision health they also advocate
for public policies that improve health
systems nationwide and provide better
access to eye health care so definitely
check out their website or their YouTube
channel and see how you can help so many
people keep the gift of sight
[Music]